this is live on Facebook my queries live
edition I'm your host Neil deGrasse
Tyson for Startalk and I got with me
Chuck nice yes so hosting that's right
hey Neil how we got were a special guest
we have Natalya Reagan we're thinking
about making her one of our all-stars
but you'll be the judge of this today
she's an expert on a Jewish an
anthropologist with specialty in
primates and everything they do well the
good stuff and the bad stuff that's that
I made to do jerk they can be jerks you
know humans are primates first and
foremost so we give me jerks
we're the best jerks there are it's all
the great apes but I oftentimes question
that there you go yeah so the peeler
questions coming in if not I'll keep
talking yes no actually so if you have
an inquiry for Natalia where you would
like to know something about primatology
primate sex monkey sets maybe science
and phony science of boning um you know
all these things actually apply to her
specialty this is our specialty and then
of course people are always going to
call it I mean going to chime in with
questions for you Neil you know that
that's always the case so that's what we
have and as they come in I'll pick them
out and I will give them to you but
first I'll let you know that the reason
why we do these Startalk face book lives
is so that we can engage you and tell
you about Startalk all-access calm
everything that we do can be found on
Startalk all-access comm commercial-free
no matter what it is but then we also
have exclusive original content
featuring the man himself dr. Neil
deGrasse Tyson sometimes sometimes
sometimes yeah and and the things that
you will not be able to see anywhere
else we actually create the content we
place it there did we also do things
like you do interviews with tons and
tons of celebrities and we don't always
use them yeah there's a lot of stuff
left over that just doesn't fit hey you
got to put it somewhere it all lands and
all that access yeah so we want to let
you know about that so let us get to do
primates hey John Clemons buddy
what's up man how are you thanks for
tuning in and John Clement says to
primates have similar rates of non
hetero romantic relationships as humans
is their behavior ever linked to the
population density so are there gay
monkeys and are they gay because they're
like is too many monkeys in sausage
party might as well make the most right
exactly which are just just a baseline
it so the percentage in the general
population of human Apes is though I say
that you would yeah yeah yes and let it
sit for a twenty ten and fifteen percent
and that's the thing is I always preface
this but with sexuality is a spectrum
and so there's a lot of sexuality or
homosexuality behavior in non-human
primates however to say that that monkey
is strictly homosexual is hard to
basically deduce by just watching a
little bit of their behavior because
even though researchers are out there
studying their behavior they're not
going to see that what they're doing at
all hours of the day see what they're
doing when that when they want to do
with what they're doing when they you're
not looking not to say that they're
there can't be a monkey that only our
innate that only is like I I just love
the fact that there's a monkey somewhere
going we can't do it now
why didn't I watch another monkey wait
the other monkeys like it's okay I like
it when she what
well I'm reminded like that David
Letterman's had monkey cam remember that
has a little camera on the head and put
cameras on the top of all the heads of
the monkeys well they're right well they
are actually are starting to do well in
camera traps can catch a lot of really
cool activity and I actually would love
to do that kind of work because I think
it's you can catch so if you don't know
that fully but we have some estimates at
all
not about an actual percentage of what
okay you know primates are college eyes
there's not a definitive answer but as
far as homosexual behavior we see it a
lot in I mean bonobos for instance are
our closest genetic relatives or
chimpanzees and bonobos about
equidistant from humans or we have a
genetic distance exactly yeah about six
seven million years back we have a
common ancestor but they are known for
lots of homosexual behavior female with
female males two males males with males
males will have sword fights it's what
it sounds well
really short right no no no other
they're far more advanced than we are
because quite frankly that doesn't
happen in the locker room you just don't
see iri did i challenge you to a duel
yeah settle the fight this way here it
is fellas we're gonna settle this like
real men check it out now samurai swords
actually wait but but do they pee their
name in the snow that's what I really
want to know I'm the only monkeys we can
really ask her Japanese snow macaque so
maybe we need to do a little odd way I
just fascinating to watch right they are
fascinating to watch in their hot tubs
chillin you know how do you know so much
about monkeys what do you do what do you
do when he's made here she's supposed to
know about Chris she study this and you
are comedian well you can get your
material okay alright yeah you know the
question alright let's go on god this
was a great question for you both which
this thing moves up so quickly
Giap plague
sorry job if that J a ap blue Agra I
think that's your name but anyway he
says so do you think primates enjoy
watching the stars at night Neil and
Natalia that's a very good question good
question
no cuz you know we look up yeah okay um
Pandu I'll go first or you want to go
first I mean I just actually I don't
have an answer but I have a perspective
to offer sure I don't have an actual
because I haven't watched Apes yeah they
go to bed just the things they actually
go to sleep they a day they really
follow the rhythms of the except there
are nocturnal primates which makes me
wonder like owl monkeys which have these
big beautiful orbs there's tarsiers yeah
for I via certain lorises are nocturnal
so that would be something maybe to ask
if I actually might have a sit down for
slow loris I'm definitely gonna bring
that up well so for me what I notice is
that we're one of the few animals that
is perfectly content sleeping on our
back because most animals that would be
a very dangerous thing to do with your
belly exposed right so we are perfectly
content sleeping on our back and we
sleep at night and if you ever wake up
at night if you're on your back you
looking up hmm so that has always been
my invented explanation for why we
development look up and you see very few
other animals wandering while staring at
the sky right but we will do that even
if you're not trained to do so
so the first cosmologists was a guy with
insomnia one person or could be a woman
yeah woman yeah yeah is that it's Omni
act human you thank you for his work
perfectly they're sleeping on our back
and also quadrupeds if you think about
it you're on all fours your natural
position is not that it's not with all
four legs exactly like this yeah and
also tree cover if you're Allah if
you're sleeping in the canopy that's
something to think about which are very
much a part of our ancestry sleeping in
trees yeah you imagine little children
quadrupedal canopy dwellers they say
mommy daddy what's beyond the canopy no
one will ever know I have an invasive
science yet right one day we will have
special tools all right all right so
Angie suave Angie suave says this I saw
an article that says eight now have
entered the Stone Age
can you explain what this means yeah so
tool use is really interesting in any in
humans you know it's something that we
we think that sets us apart but a lot of
actual non-human primates not just Apes
but actual monkeys use tools to break
open mind everybody ate monkey oh yeah
so there's apes and monkeys which are
chooses in the in the tree of primates
we belong to the family of great apes
and the figurative tree of primates
because they otherwise live in trees
primates in it in life monkeys are
different the easiest ways they have it
you can just see if they have a tail not
that right there is a monkey so if you
go to a zoo you get that gorilla is not
a monkey it is an ape and if I remember
correctly my anthropology that humans
are Apes are more closely related to one
another genetically than either of us
are to the old world monkeys yeah yeah
absolutely
and so but but back to the question
we'll use it yeah to end in Stone Age
yeah so I I don't know if it's
necessarily with it
they might have been in a tool or the
Stone Age for a while now because I mean
again we don't always see everything
that we they do but you see them using
not only sticks for fishing out termites
and there's actually evidence that
there's different groups that are using
different light lengths of sticks to
fish out specific termites because they
have a specific preference for a
particular day see why it's a pathogenic
and I know somebody who studied like
this one really aggressive type of ant
the one chimps one group of chimps on
one side of the river we can use the six
foot long not six along I was like
longer than like eight foot long sticks
to get these you know ants out and eat
them but the ones on the other side the
river were like I'm not messing with
those guys don't let them have no
interests right but as far as like you
know and female chimp sauce actually
they found recently Jill preached who's
a fantastic primatologist studies chimps
and she discovered that female chimps
which are not known to hunt like male
chimps do males chimps will go on these
shorter maraj where they go around and
they will hunt these monkeys because
chimps like to eat monkeys mm-hm
but the females were taking sticks and
twigs and poking and trees and basically
killing bush babies and eating them so
they're they're using would they ever
use a stone as a as a weapon
well I mean to crack open nuts and
shellfish but not to stone to death
another well you would oh they're pretty
brutal some of I guess they would be a
dating no give it I mean I don't vote
mostly they use their they're so strong
physically that they don't necessarily
need tools yeah and they say martial
arts so they got rid of constipation
wait so so just quick so so if this were
to evolve further they would go from
Stone Age to the Iron Age hey and then
they're like smell pee ah that would be
good it's time to get off the planet
kind of leave game of monkeys off yeah
exactly a game of clowns don't you got
Chuck here's a good one from Nicola
McKenna and Nicola says this how
carnivorous are primates hmm that's a
great question so diet is really
interesting in in primates because one
of the things that people think of is
when they think of teeth they think that
hates what they eat inside yeah they
have canines and incisors
like gorillas for instance like King
Kong's just came out you know you see
gorilla you know King Kong looking like
this is terrorizing you know carnivore
gorillas are primarily vegetarian they
eat like the occasional bug or glittered
here or there but chimpanzees love to
eat in particular colobus monkeys red
colobus monkeys and so they will go away
right and then the world so it is not
necessarily a percentage of like this X
amount of monkey or you know yeah we
can't see all that they're doing but
we're discovering more and more that
they will you know opportunistically
like culling humans we opportunistically
eat things we've obviously come into a
modern time where we have a grocery
store bodega down the street so we can
eat anything at any particular time
where opportunity we eat Lucky Charms
breakfast cereal good without it is st.
Patrick's Day this moment it is so yeah
and there are specific primates like for
instance I studied spider monkey spider
monkeys are frugivores meaning they eat
primarily fruit that's what their works
active with a pretty large frugal or rid
of the de fuga world right fruits like a
Fraggle
I love birds they're delicious moles
Krug I now need to draw this region and
then there's you know howler monkeys and
colobus monkeys that are caught you know
Paula Bynes which are a group of monkeys
that eat mostly leaves there are fall of
wars right another word of the day so
basically you've got you how to run the
gambit yeah pretty much then there's
humans which are just basically doors
right we can eat anything
what's interesting that's why we rule
the planet no that's not going to say
this macaque switch are the second most
diver or a distributed primate or like
us don't need anything anything which
ensures your survival it means they take
over next hahaha yeah eating awesome
those okay he's really awesome I'm not
yes exactly good yeah this is great man
we are out of time believe it
time we are because we're running over
studio time our studio time is over and
guys thank you so much to all of you
David John Arlen Ohio Thank You Natalia
thank you we hit you back on anything
yes okay I'm I'm in you got more you got
more eight stories that make yeah
totally and we have the hypertrophic
clitoris of the SpiderMonkey don't know
exactly why I did that
yes okay right all right listen there's
more to come and remember everything
that we do you can find on Startalk
all-access comm we'll be posting this
later so that you know spread the word
kind of retweet it put it out there
because it's on periscope as well as
Facebook live right now and hey yeah you
know thank you for tuning in and we hope
to see you again and as always keep
looking up yeah yep we out if you like
this please remember everything that we
do can be found commercial-free plus
exclusive original content all on
Startalk all-access calm